le renseignement un monde plein de
fantasmes alimenté notamment par les
nombreuses séries télévisées sur le
sujet c'est pour ouvrir le secteur vers
les domaines universitaires que science
pause saint germain en laye propose
cette formation le dira m comprenait
diplômes d'établissement sur le
renseignement et les menaces globales a
été développé avec l'académie du
renseignement
sciences po saint germain en laye c'est
un jeune institut d'études politiques
mais qui en son sein dispose d'une
équipe très engagé sur ces questions de
sécurité de violence de lutte contre le
terrorisme
puisque nous sommes associés à un
laboratoire de recherche qui s'appelle
le cesdip qui est très orienté sur les
questions de sécurité les questions les
questions pénales de façon générale le
diplôme est organisé en 6 sessions de
trois jours consécutifs qui se
dérouleront d'octobre à mars
une formation de 160 heures environ
divisé en trois grands modules un module
sur les menaces contemporaines un module
sur le renseignement et un module sur
les pratiques et les techniques il
chaque module comporte quatre courts 4
petit cours d'histoire les des cours sur
l'économie du crime organisé un cours
sur le djihadisme salafistes un cours
sur la violence politique et la
radicalisation un cours sur la cyber
menaces ces cours seront donnés par des
professeurs d'université et des
professionnels du milieu eux-mêmes
diversité de profils chez les élèves
formation initiale pour les étudiants
bac +4 formation en continu pour les
agents des services de renseignement des
gens en poste
c'est une manière pour tout
professionnel d'avoir un éclairage
universitaire bénéficier
les derniers résultats de la recherche
une vingtaine d'étudiants composera
chaque année la promotion du diplôme les
inscriptions à la formation sont
ouvertes jusqu'au 28 juin prochain